forget the Chinese company right to buy
dance owns Tick Tock just take Airbnb
for example not a lot of people know
this but this is like front page Wall
Street Journal reporting three years ago
I wrote about a little bit more in my
book
Airbnb American company headquartered in
Silicon Valley ESG Darling by the way
puts a neat little black Square on its
Instagram account to stand solidarity
with black lives matter okay what do
they do they are literally handing over
the American user data on their platform
including private messages between
people who rent and the hosts on their
platform geolocational data Etc as a
condition for doing business in China
they don't get to do business in China
unless they hand that over do they tell
us users that they're doing it
absolutely not wow did their Chief
privacy officer resign yes he did but
you know Nate blacharchik he was a
couple years ahead of me in college what
did he say he was quoted and saying it
internally at their meeting we're not
here we're saying we're not here to
promote American values so we in America
are fine with that we think that
companies should not exist to promote
American values they should exist to
sell goods and services but the problem
is on a global stage China does believe
that those companies exist to promote
Chinese values and unless they abide by
that they don't get to do business there
so that's how they've actually turned
our own game on its head and here we are
playing along going along for the ride
10 years from now if we wake up to today
I think there's something we can do
about it 10 years from now wait to wake
up to this we're done it's toast I mean
same with our lack of capital controls
this is especially a problem in Canada
but you have all of these Chinese
property buyers who are not only buying
residential areas you know entire
projects but also buying up things like
ports right so it's it's not just the
financial system we're actually talking
about physicality China owns the West
this is not even mentioning the amount
of dollars that they have in reserve
right so I I get that people are saying
oh this is a problem we need to address
militarily China doesn't really need to
lift a finger in terms of arms to I I
would say fatally hurt the American
system at this point they have police
departments inside of the United States
and Canada from the Chinese government I
mean they have a lot of sphere of
influence but they wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for Henry Kissinger and David
Rockefeller going over there and opening
up China to the world that's the nice
phrase that they use but in in all
actuality they just used China as a
vehicle to spread globalization they
took all the factory jobs from the
United States they shipped it over there
and they made a deal with with China
saying hey we're going to be working
with you guys one-on-one this is the
pathway by Henry Kissinger that led us
here and now we're in this situation
that you're describing so you're totally
right all right because I'm just screwed
up
no no no no no Kissinger doesn't screw
up Kissinger I think is is a brilliant
human being and I think a lot of his
screw-ups actually do benefit a lot of
his friends okay because I'm just
screwed up in screwed up maybe the wrong
word screwed up yes
everyone else over for the benefits
policies usually these legacies screwed
us okay now though that's the easy part
identifying that in the rear view mirror
and blaming you know correctly correctly
assigning blame is the first step fine
what do we do about it the question is
there is a going to be a sacrifice it is
not a small sacrifice it will be very
big sacrifice an economic sacrifice that
we're gonna have to be willing to make
to say that we're not going to defeat an
enemy who we depend on to supply our
iPhones and our movies and the sneakers
that we wear on a given day is that a
sacrifice we're willing to make we're
not even willing to make a sacrifice to
ban Tick Tock cause kids are so addicted
to it what level of sacrifice are we
going to be willing to make it goes back
to the thing I said earlier it's like
given cocaine to the drug addict okay if
the drug addict can't say no to the
thing they're addicted to they're just
heading in their in down the road to the
black hole of their own misery that's
where we are in our relationship with
China right now we don't have it in us
we don't have the fortitude to cut
ourselves off from the Comforts that
we're going to have to give up in the
short run in order to fix this for the
long run well if you look at China's
model of economic nationalism there are
things that the U.S could copy
essentially and and ensure that they
take greater control of their own
companies their own Capital but like you
said they're not going to do it and I
bring this back to movies because again
mediaholic Channel China you actually
they limit the number of foreign movies
that you can bring into China every
single year and obviously China is this
huge market for movies a lot of Revenue
so what Hollywood does is that they
actually do joint Partnerships with
Chinese production so if you ever
wondered why there are so many different
movies that are filmed in places like
Shanghai and Hong Kong counts for these
purposes though it's an SAR it is
because if you partner with Chinese
production then you get to skirt around
the quota now you're no longer one of
the made 10 films or whatever it may be
that they released from foreign foreign
production houses now you actually count
as local so you can give as many movies
as you want in China you take a greater
share of the cut and what that means is
that actually Hollywood is funding the
Chinese Communist party uh and and it's
it's a smart move but you see the United
States like you said they would never
ever do something that bold I guess that
economic not economically National
they're not strong enough to do the one
thing I would say Lord is is one thing
we've got to be careful of and I see
this a little bit of this sloppiness on
the right sometimes there could be two
very different justifications for taking
similar courses of policy one is just
straight up economically protectionist
which is to say that oh they took our
jobs and you know we need to we need to
you know they're they're making stuff
cheaper than we are here I'm not super
sympathetic to the economically
protectionist account of giving and
coddling the American worker what I'm
talking about is the National Security
side of the line and actually it turns
out that a lot of these policies can
point in the same direction but when
China is viewing economic policy and
military policy as two sides of the same
coin I think that when it comes to a
national security question we got to
treat it as a national security issue
that defends us against the one threat
that actually matters to the United
States the thought in Iraq Afghanistan
Russia Ukraine is China but I think that
we got to be careful not to make that a
sloppy way into anti-meritocratic
American worker coddling which I think
we could use less of rather than more
even though sometimes on the right
people end up conflating you know a lot
of that's where I part ways with Josh
Hawley and whatnot is the justification
for taking courses of action that might
make sense for National Security grounds
don't work for me if it's just
anti-meritocratic laziness well I think
we're at a point now where people would
be more willing to accept some economic
protectionism if it's in the name of
National Security after covid right
because so many people saw that hey we
don't actually make a lot of drugs in
the United States anymore we don't make
a lot of PPE in the United States
anymore so there are definitely certain
industries where I think people would be
willing to say let's make the sacrifice
in order to support American Business we
already see that historically with
American Steel right because we
understand the importance of wartime I I
don't think people would be as willing
to do that for when it comes to those
cheap Goods that we can get at the
dollar store right because the the
average consumer is going to think why
am I paying more for I I don't know
whatever it may be my toothbrush now for
for my iPhone now like how is this part
of National Security that would be a
really hard sell in terms of policy to
the to the public
I don't have an answer for that
yeah I mean I think I think any time the
litmus test for me is if China is using
a company as a vehicle to advance a
geopolitical goal we need to treat that
as what it is it is a geopolitical
question it is a security question it is
not just an economic question where does
that leave us probably Banning Tick Tock
um I think I think I mean not just Tick
Tock
NBA as well we see them pushing this
leftist agenda they have big contracts
with China and they won't say a thing
about free speech I mean it's it's even
something as simple some might say
apolitical as Sports there's also the
economic incentive like China is in that
they are controlling that that's why
Lebron James despite all his BLM
activism won't say a thing about the
Euchre Muslims yeah I mean these are
again circus monkeys of the CCP as I
said earlier do you think there could be
a market solution to this because I'm
thinking about this and I just don't
want the government deciding what we can
and cannot see I think a bigger solution
and this is just me being optimistic is
giving people uh an internet Bill of
Rights where you have your data you
protect your data and I I think the
reason why they're all this sabotaged
and spying and fifth generational
Warfare is going on because it's not
just benefiting the Chinese it's also
benefiting the American deep state
they're getting data sets they're that
Facebook knows when you take a dump they
know everything you do and they have
garnered so much about to give birth
exactly because I was Googling like
pregnancy stuff they knew that newborn
was coming but there's advertisements
being sent to mothers that that are sent
before they even know that they're
pregnant themselves based on their
behaviors and activities that they come
in on social media so so I I think the
once that moving forward is saying hey
your data you control it uh and if you
want to sell it to another company you
have that right to do that is there a
possibility for that to happen rather
than the government coming in and just
Banning these accounts because I think
also there needs to be a lot more public
awareness at the severity of just this
kind of deep State spying that's
happening I mean I've seen Libertarians
argue that even something like a Bill of
Rights for the internet would be
government action in and of itself
because you can't forget if there's an
internet Bill of Rights that'll also
necessitates that there's some sort of
penalty or enforcement so so I think
you're talking about fancy Solutions in
terms of Market Solutions I think
there's actually lower hanging fruit
just to keep it even simpler I think in
the same way that globalization
represented an opportunity in the 1990s
from it just from its raw investment
perspective I think de-globalization
represents a massive investment
opportunity
from a capital allocation perspective
over the next 10 years ahead as well and
you know so I'll give you I'll give you
one small example right I Still Company
I've done business in China before by
the way and I was exchange student my
senior year of college at Peking
University that's you know sort of the
Harvard of China they call it done
business in China thereafter I've seen
what that looks like
I I said that what I found at strive I
said look we're not going to do business
in China we're not we're going to make
that commitment on day one why do I say
that is that because I dislike the CCP I
personally dislike the CCP it has
nothing to do with it as to with the
fact that you can't be a good fiduciary
to an American Consumer managing an
American's funds
speaking as a vocal shareholder on
behalf of American clients if you have
the boot of the CCP on your neck now I
think that that is actually a business
opportunity to operate with greater
Integrity serving the American consumer
unapologetically in a way that the
pendulum when it swung so far in One
Direction you know is sort of a classic
maxim of Warren Buffett be brave when
others are fearful be fearful when
others are brave to actually be contrary
and go in the other direction to be an
even better Steward for the American
customer by differentiating yourself by
making sure that the thing that
differentiates you is that you are not
under the bear hug or under the auspic
or with a gun to your head from the CCP
and so I I just think that
de-globalization broadly and a
willingness to invest to serve the
citizens of Nations rather than Global
Citizens can itself be an economic
opportunity that defines probably great
businesses that can be built on the back
of that over the next decade now
operationalizing that into an internet
through a tech-based infrastructure or
the blockchain or whatever ever else I
mean that that gets complicated Free
Speech Bill of Rights or or Internet
Bill of Rights you know that those are
all thorny issues we could spend a five
hour discussion on in their own right
but I just think about even basic
business Builders and entrepreneurs
stepping up and saying that I can in
order to put my American customer first
that itself is a business opportunity
that I can liberate myself from even if
that means sacrificing the extra 30 of
the opportunity that I could have gotten
by going to China I think we're going to
see more of that Lauren if I could just
ask you because I grew up in Poland
during communism my family tells me all
these crazy stories about what they have
to go through because of the the KGB and
the government there do you have similar
stories growing up in China does your
family tell you stories of of maybe how
the social credit score was being put
into place or anything like that I
mostly grew up in Hong Kong my dad is
Cantonese from Hong Kong
um I My Views about uh I guess the
benefits versus cons of British
colonialism have gotten me on trouble
and Trouble on on Twitter many a time
um so you know my my parents they
they've been in Hong Kong during things
like the umbrella the protests and
personally I've witnessed that every
time I go back to Hong Kong you see more
and more actual propaganda and for
anyone who's not familiar with Hong Kong
it is one of the most developed and I
guess financially free places on on the
planet right 15 was right 15 flat tax uh
you know you're walking down the Main
Street and they're all these Major
Brands uh Dior Schnell you name it now
with CCP propaganda covered over it so
this is absolutely absolutely something
that's gotten increasingly worse over
the past past few years and you know
there's footage of people doing things
like trying to rip down uh those those
data hubs essentially that are are
trying to monitor your face so this is
something that I mean you know it's even
more recent and that's what's so scary
about it because you you hear about
these losses of freedoms and you think
maybe Soviet Union or a generation ago
you know maybe even further back but no
this is actually some freedoms are
actually something that you can lose in
real time and heck even I'm gonna bring
it to Canada that my nationalities have
not been uh doing too well in terms of
safe fighting Liberties I'm also
Canadian it's the same I'm saying in
Canada as well I mean you're freezing
bank accounts now so like where where
are these people supposed to go at a
certain point when literally I would say
most nations are backsliding yeah I mean
I was in Hong Kong during a lot of the
protests there and the way that the
Chinese government squashes protests and
and the measures that they put in is
absolutely terrifying I I've talked to a
lot of the protesters there I've done on
the ground reporting I was in the tear
gas I was in the craziness and just the
level of sophistication when it comes to
their intelligence surveillance State
Police state it is terrifying right and
I think I you know I've spoken with my
husband about this before uh if we are
in a situation where Liberty is
essentially dissolving everywhere we go
I would rather live in a state that is
at least less physically and
technologically capable of oppressing
you and than one that is right which is
why there are so many people that I know
just personally incompetent dictatorship
rather than a competent one exactly
you're right and that's something that I
think Rousseau has kind of written about
I I would rather are at least a dictator
who's only got a limited reach due to
limited resources rather than I mean
somewhere like Hong Kong like China like
Canada and I would say in a lot of ways
yeah like Europe thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time